okay we're going to try to get started
in about a minute
okay welcome to state federal veterans
uh it's 902 it's starting a minute late
but that's due to the weather we try to
be on time and I'd like to ask represent
fenney if you would lead us in the
pledge
okay again welcome to state federal and
veterans
we have a hearing this morning on five
different measures
um we have some folks that are on their
way we have some subs coming in there's
obviously some weather but we will dance
with who comes to the party
and
thankfully representative Newell is at
our party this morning the prime sponsor
for uh HB 392. welcome representative
Newell
thank you Mr chairman and thank you all
for coming out I think I was just
running alongside one of these guys
trying to get here in time
um let me see
so my name is Jody Knoll I'm
representing Cheshire four uh which is a
little slice I haven't over there in
Keene and I just wanted to give a quick
introduction to this bill and I'm going
to need to scoot off so
um I know you have all heard a couple
Article 5 convention calls and a
delegate instructions Bill and so I
really don't think I need to flesh out
the concept I think you guys probably
are pretty familiar with that you've
seen as well as I have although I'm sure
more on account of the seats you hold on
this committee
plenty of emails from folks concerned
about a well-funded effort to rewrite
the Constitution by nefarious actors
this is a concern I'm very familiar with
I actually got involved with this
movement I first visited this building
as a volunteer for an organization
called wolf pack which is a Grassroots
funded uh group of volunteers reading
doj ABA and CRS reports in our spare
time and talking to legislators about
the best solution we knew of how to uh
to address the corruption of our
democracy our issue was a corrupting
issue of the corrupting influence of
money in politics
with Citizens United and all the other
cases whose precedent it was built on
with the body directly benefiting from
this corruption tasked with addressing
it fixing this issue surely seemed
insurmountable
but there is a way because the one thing
that the Supreme Court is beholden to is
the Constitution
now I know you've all heard about
but
good morning it being 9 15. I am hereby
opening the public hearing or reopening
the public hearing on HB 38 excuse me
not public hearing executive session let
me just give me a second to realize
Where We Are
and I will recognize representative
Rhodes for a motion
chairman I would like to move
um retain for house bill 38.
is there a second
representative Stone seconds our second
would you like to speak to your motion
yes thank you Mr chairman just very
briefly we've heard several bills
already
um
bail and or bail Commissioners and I
think that the best thing to do right
now is retain these and kind of put them
together and see what we can come up
with
representative Stone would you like to
speak to you a second
I would concur with representative
Rhodes
thank you
um I'll I'll lead off any discussion um
by saying the following I have conferred
with the court system I've conferred
with our colleagues any other body
and I have also conferred with um the
ACLU and and several other folks who
have testified including Professor share
and we are working on
um combining and several versions of
this and we're going to retain just
about all of these bills so that we can
work on them over the summer the courts
right now are very tied up with felonies
first and we're going to defer a little
bit to let them get their feet on the
ground with that so that we can come in
this fall with a good version that takes
all of these into account and covers all
the concerns addressed by these various
bills so for anyone with concerns we're
not
um we're not closing the door on these
we're just holding on to them so we can
further work on them and distill down
a good piece of legislation that is
going to move through both bodies and is
going to capture all the concerns that
everybody has with the current system
and with that I'll open it up for any
further comments representative Newman
yeah I have a question the first one is
you said all of these bills I'm assuming
that you meant all of the bail
type bills as opposed to all of the
bills on
okay as convenient as that would be no
just just wanted to make sure for a
minute maybe I was having flashbacks
um
the other thing is would could you just
please go through what it means to
retain a bill and what effect that has
on next year and who gets to vote on it
at the end of the end all of those kind
of things so that everybody understands
what exactly retained means thank you
that's a good idea when we retain a bill
what it simply means is the committee
holds on to the bill
and it's still alive available for us
what it does basically is just gives us
more time we have to address the bill
this fall with either the same same
results of an itl or not to pass it just
gives us more time to work on the bill
retained means we're going to hold on to
it we're going to do some more work on
it but we still have to come to the same
set of conclusions one way or the other
that we would have if we would have
acted on it right now
is that and the only follow-up I have to
that I I don't I don't never did fully
understand what happens at the end of
the year that if you have to act on it
and is it the way I think it might work
is that you vote whether it can be heard
in the next session or whether it is has
the motion that passes that that it
doesn't get hurt is that
um close
um somewhat close what would happen is
let's use this as an example let's say
we took five bills that had to do with
bail and we worked on one of them and
amended it so that it encompassed pieces
of all the other bills
we would then
itl the other bills the one bill that we
have would be OTP and that would be
taken up as as we sat again in January
thank you very much
any other questions or comments
seeing none I will excuse me go ahead
representative Muse
and just a quick comment um all of these
bills deal with systemic changes in the
uh in the judicial and criminal justice
system and
um these changes uh tend to have tend to
be far far ranging in terms of their
impact they also tend to be uh not cheap
so putting the brakes on this a little
bit so that we can actually make a
better decision and have a better bill I
think is a is a better outcome in the
long term and and I do recognize that
there are still some pain points that
need to be addressed in the short term
um but what I would what I would hope is
that some of the testimony that we've
heard during this bill and with some of
the other bills would lead uh would lead
folks to be more aware of perhaps how
some of those pain points could be
addressed uh in the short term to
alleviate the situation somewhat until
we actually have a systemic solution so
I just wanted to say that you know we're
we're aware of the urgency
um but we're also aware of the need to
pass good uh and thoughtful legislation
thanks
I would concur with everything that you
just said I would also um add to it that
we are going to continue working with
all of the stakeholders in this to
include the bail Commissioners to
include the courts to include just about
everyone that that has had an opinion on
it so far and I'm not going to make a
subcommittee over this this is important
so I intend to work on it as a full
committee as we go along so everyone
will have input representative Sally
thank you Mr chair I have a procedural
question as a new representative so
um we have I forget maybe let's say five
bills on bail reform issues if if we're
aware that like four of them have
components that we think are really
workable but one we feel is has enough
uh misguidance that we really don't
think it should even
be com considered with the others how to
how do we handle do we then vote
I guess
um any Bill we retain whether or not we
feel it has Merit or not would be
handled just as if we handled it today
so if at the end after we've worked on
all these and come up with a good piece
of legislation even the ones that have
Merit will be itl'd in favor of the one
that took pieces from all of the others
and the ones that never had any Merit in
the first place so we will just deal
with them as if we dealt with them today
I just don't want to I don't want to
Telegraph uh something that I don't
intend by italing one bill today and
leaving the rest I want to make sure
that we look at each piece and give it a
it's due weight because all of them do
have expenses and do
will affect the criminal justice system
in the state for many years to come so I
think it's worth looking at everything
in depth
sure go ahead thank you Mr chairman
representative the only thing I would
like to add that I think was maybe part
of your question is each one of each and
every single bill will be voted on
separately as an individual bill so I
may have misled when I said you know
kind of mush these whatever word I used
each one will still be individually
voted on as it is that is that better
yes thank you I I worry where we were
aware that like one of them in
particular seems to have a lot of
unconstitutional elements but others
seem to have more components that we can
navigate just making sure we're not
um punting something that will
ultimately get us into deeper hot water
yeah and there's no commitment to
anything by retaining it representative
Bolden
thanks
um going off of all that conversation
so I'm imagining that your plan is to
have work sessions that are announced
that are on all of the bills on this
topic
um and they'll be full committee
um and that eventually we might drum up
some kind of amendment pick a bill to
amend kill the rest and move forward
with one bill
um and so I just wanted to suggest and
you do not have to decide today
um but maybe I believe you have the
option to hold a public hearing on
whatever we ultimately put together if
you want to and I don't know if that
would be a good step or if we just get
testimony repeating what we've already
heard but if it's significantly
different it may be worthwhile thank you
um I agree and I I think that our work
sessions are public so I think that
anyone who cares will probably attend
them anyway and if we alter alter the
subject matter so much that it it
requires a public hearing to re
um talk about the issues I certainly
will will do that but we can discuss
that as a committee
representative Newman and and my
question is
the all of these bills that deal with
this will eventually go through this
committee because where they are all
subject to Second committee to come here
for that kind of stuff okay because I
don't know if there are any in any other
committees
I'm not sure that there are but I know
that the other body has some too that
will be brought and worked on at the
same time at the crossover so yeah all
roads lead to Rome
and you're the emperor
and thankfully I have clothes
with that we will um
the clerk will call the roll
we'll be taking that bill up in a little
bit
Vice chair Rhodes
uh representative Pratt
yes
representative Hill yes
representative sellers
yes
representative janvin
representative Manion
yes
representative Reed
representative Stone yes
representative tensar
yes
representative Harriet gathright
representative Muse
yes
representative Bolden
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes
the clerk votes yes representative
Newell yes
representative selig yes representative
wheeler
and Mr chair
wood yes
all right the total is 20 yay zero
motion passes
um Mr chair
are we putting things on consent
because I think we do have to explicitly
discuss it and agree to it on a retain I
don't think oh we do no thanks my bad
okay
and this time I'm closing the executive
session on HP 38
and opening the executive session on
eight it's okay we're not going to do it
HV 318
um Bill eliminating bail Commissioners
again this is going to fall into the
previous one so I'm hoping that we do
not need to reiterate our previous
discussion when I will be recognizing um
representative janvin for a motion
Mr chair I move to retain HB 318 FNA
second okay
seconded by representative Harry
gathwright
um Mr representative Jammer would you
like to speak to your motion
I would just say that um
along with House Bill 38 the the intent
is to Frankenstein a bill at the end of
the session
very good um second would you like to
speak to your second
no okay well said Frankenstein stays
um
there being no further discussion I will
ask the clerk to please call the roll
Vice chair Rhodes yes
representative Pratt yes
representative Hill
representative sellers
yes
representative janvin
representative Manion
yes representative Reed
representative Stone yes representative
tenzai yes
representative Harriet gothright
representative Muse yes representative
Bolden
yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes
the clerk votes yes representative
Newell yes
representative selig yes
representative wheeler
chair Roy
CE yes
the total is 20 yes zero no motion
passes
at this point I close the public hearing
on HB 318.
close the executive session on HP 318
and open the executive session on hb504
and I recognize representative Reed for
a motion
thank you Mr chairman I move to itl Bill
504 Dash FN
second
would you like to speak to your motion
thank you Mr chairman the bill the bill
504 fni FN allows for the appointment of
a previous adult board
parole board amends the stipend for the
vice chair of the said board and makes
an appropriation to the board
the important service the parole board
serves and the amount of time a member
dedicates to the performance of their
duties and increase in expenditures by
51 500 dollars
thank you
representative mannion would you like to
speak to you a second did he make the
second
no I think she covered it thank you
discussion
excuse me
representative here at Gathering right
this cold weather is messing with my
asthma so if my voice goes out that's
the reason
um
we heard testimony from the board on
several occasions over the last year and
last week that they're having a problem
actually meeting because if two two
people are there they don't are gone
they don't have enough coverage so we
already know that they're behind and so
they come to us for help
I can't understand why we would be Ito
on this bill
I believe that that's part of our duty
to help and he's asked for at least five
days or five meetings
um a year
I think that that's pretty good I
personally I think he's going to need
more than that okay the way the courts
and everything are backed up and how
people are trying to get parole and
those things of that nature
so um we actually had a finance person
that actually wrote the Bill and so and
and knowing knowing that I truly believe
that she's already looked at the
finances
you know so
and felt that we would be able to cover
that otherwise I truly don't believe the
bill would have been written so if there
was a question about the finance I truly
believe that we should have gone to
finance and inquire instead of putting
it out there that we don't have the
funds and you know so
thank you
at this time I'm going to recess this
bill for five minutes and we will pick
it up again in five minutes Republican
members of the committee could you
please meet me in the uh my office
thank you
so
much
foreign
I'm reopening the executive session
on
hb504 and I'm going to recognize
representative Reed
thank you Mr chairman um I would like to
withdraw make a motion to withdraw
um my previous itl
and change it to okay
would you be willing to withdraw your
emotion I will yes thank you uh
recognize representative Reed for a new
motion
I would like to make a move that to make
Bill 504 on OT p in ought to pass and do
I hear a second
okay
did you get those
would you like to speak to your motion
representative Reed
Mr chairman after test uh hearing from
representative Garth Cartwright she made
some very good gather rights she made
excuse me she made some very good points
and
um at that point we decided to change
thank you
representative um Manuel would you like
to speak to you a second no that covers
it saying okay situation
um I would add that as a point for the
reflection we are a policy committee and
I we agree with the policy of being able
to backfill those slots and we agree
that they need some more money and um
with regard to how much you want percent
um we'll let Finance discuss that and I
think it's not an outrageous amount
they've asked for so
um we're going to go ahead and any
further discussion
representative salic
thank you Mr chair I just would like to
say one of the things that I appreciated
was the recognition
from the people who presented the bill
and testified about it that their goal
is not to have substantial increases but
to accommodate their committee with
experienced members for known absences
so that they can ensure that their
process happens in a timely manner
that's a point well taken and I think
that one of the things that we've
reflected on is the specialty required
in these positions that to backfill it
and to fill these positions you have to
be able to offer some reasonable
enumeration for lawyers and people that
to take away from their private practice
to come in and serve
further discussion
representative Newman
and I'd like to thank you for your
comments and I think that we I would
just like to say that we are in fact a
policy committee and we should consider
policy we should get the policy right
and make sure that's what we want to do
and if there's a financial problem with
it then the finance committee will
determine whether or not they have the
resources to be able to let that because
we'll go to the second committee for
financing
again Point well taken so you know
further I will ask the clerk to please
call the roll
Vice chair roads yes
representative Pratt
yes
representative Hill yes representative
sellers yes
representative janvin
yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed
representative Stone yes
representative tanzar yes
representative Harriet gathright
representative Muse yes representative
Bolden yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes
the clerk votes yes representative
Newell yes
representative selig yes
representative wheeler
chair Roy
CE yes
total is 20 years zero names motion
passes any objection consent
and Beyond consent
and this time I close the public excuse
me the executive session HP 504 and open
the executive session hb643
and I recognize representative Pratt for
a motion
I make a motion of itl on House Bill 643
is there a second
tens our seconds
second number representative tensar
representative Pratt would you like to
speak to your motion
the motion of itl for 643 is because of
unintended consequences this bill to
legalized cannabis has led to damaging
consequences in other states around the
country
this will lead to an increase in
cannabis availability advertising public
consumption possible addiction driving
Under the Influence accidents less
attendance at jobs in schools it has
been been stated that this is needed to
relieve pain but the pain suffering to
society will increase and not decrease
representative tensor would you like to
speak to you second
president uh Pratt said it well
I'll open discussion by saying
as a as a committee we um there are
several bills in another committee that
deal with this issue in a much more
comprehensive Manner and and have
bipartisan support
um and I look forward to seeing those um
above the ones we currently have so I'm
going to be supporting the uh in
expedient to legislate on this one
representative salic
thank you Mr chair
I think as a new representative she got
a little overextended in the number of
things she attempted to incorporate into
this bill and that she recognized that
there might be others that would be once
she would be happy to continue to
support
and so I just want to recognize her her
intent and dedication to the process and
recognize that while I hope we will move
forward towards supporting similar
measures that I agree this one is
probably a bit overextended
thank you and I would second that and
add to it that as a committee
um we believe in the in the good
intentions of every representative who
brings a piece of legislation forward
um and they have the best interest of
the public at heart and it's our job to
help them
um do it in the best way possible
representative Newman
um my comment deals with the situations
where we have many bills
that have good parts to them
and we just retained a situation like
that in order that we could look all of
the bills on the same subject so I my
own personal feeling is that we should
probably retain this bill and use the
same process on this category of bills
and so I will be voting against the itl
thank you um and
you're not wrong however there's only so
many months in the summer and unless you
want to spend them all here we wouldn't
be able to retain all these there is as
I said another set of bills working
their way through another committee that
uh a lot of the work will be done for us
as far as vetting and Distilling down
the best parts and I think that bill or
those bills had a head start and they
have bipartisan Sport and from both
bodies so I think for us to try and work
parallel tracks at the same time it's
not going to end and the way we hope it
would so I respect your opinion on that
though representative wheeler thank you
Mr chairman and I agree with what you
just said I don't want to be here all
summer and I I respect the intentions of
this bill and support the legalization
of marijuana and hope that some form of
legalization gets to the house floor and
passes through the legislature I don't
think state-run
Cannabis stores is the way to move
forward
the state-run liquor stores I think
presents a problem already there are
many reports of corruption and I think
adding uh products for them to sell
would not be the right thing for this
legislature to do I I think
moving forward with legalization in a
more
liberty-minded way where it's it's about
people who can grow at their homes and
people who can possess and use marijuana
if they have it is is the better way to
go rather than State sanctioned stores
uh selling marijuana so I will vote for
the itl motion on this legislation thank
you
representative Newell
I would just like to um I I while I
recognize all all points and agree with
a lot of them on principle I'm going to
be voting against the itl and what I
would like to for people to keep in mind
when we're talking about marijuana
legalization uh cannabis legalization
and things like that is the balance of
the harm that is actually being done on
behalf of it being illegal right now
people are suffering the consequences of
that people are sitting in jail there's
a variety of harms that are happening to
people actively because of it it being
criminalized so I just want to keep that
in mind as far as the personal impact as
long as we wait and our inaction has
consequences for uh citizens New
Hampshire
thank you and I I'll take that as your
support of my bill lowering the
penalties for first offense possession
that will be coming representative
Bolden
legalize it but um I support itl
um we know
what what the Liquor Commission is today
and that it was created when a substance
was re-legalized and um I think that
um arguments I've heard from
stakeholders in cannabis legalization
they make a good point that people
impacted by
the criminalization of possession of
cannabis
should have the opportunity to
participate in its legal Commerce to
kind of um reverse the wrongs of uh you
know Decades of or I guess at this point
A Century of criminalization
um especially in the way that it's
affected certain populations of people
and so to hand it over to the Liquor
Commission would deny
um some a large portion of those
opportunities with the exception of
stocking shelves
um so that's why I'm going to support
itl thanks
thank you and my heart is warmed by the
unanimous support of the free market
anyone else
um thank you Mr chair
I would just like to mention I think
that the idea of uh
state-run cannabis is not inherently bad
considering we're a state that tries to
avoid income tax and other
increases on our population but that we
also are a state that is seeking more
streams of Revenue and as of right now
anyone in New Hampshire who wants to
access cannabis can drive simply 20
minutes over the border and bring it
back into our state so we are giving
that Revenue to the states surrounding
New Hampshire because of that I will be
voting itl or voting against the itl
thank you representative wheeler I would
just uh for my friend representative
Murray urged her and anyone interested
in the Liquor Commission and what
they're doing to go to the finance
committee division one and talk to
representative Peter leishman he can go
in depth on the corruption of the Liquor
Commission and I will just reaffirm that
this is not something we should be we
will um I'd ask you to refrain from
um asserting that any official state
agency is corrupt at this point please
thank you my apologies Mr chairman
representative Murray thank you Mr chair
um just would like to say maybe it would
be worthwhile for us to investigate
um instituting cannabis Commission
you are free to write any bill you so
desire
at this point I will ask you to call the
room
sure Rhodes
representative Pratt
yes representative Hill yes
representative sellers yes
representative janvin
yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed
representative Stone yes
representative tanzai yes
representative Harriet Guthrie
representative Muse yes
representative Bolton
yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy
no
representative Newman
the clerk votes no representative Newell
no
representative selig
um
uh yes I guessed yes
oh yes
representative wheeler
chairman Roy
CE yes
all right 16 yes four no motion passes
okay that cannot go on consent
um so
yeah that's true
um
will there bring a Minority Report
we'd like to write that
who's supposedly
you got the majority Minority Report you
all right yes okay could you just go
over the timing for the completion of
the report
um if you could in this new session if
you could get it to me um by the middle
of next week by Wednesday morning that
would be great that's not a problem
today would have been a problem yeah I'm
not going to do that to you
um
and who made the motion
I did represent Pratt will you be
writing the report for the committee yes
thank you
at this point I will close the public
hearing on
hb6 excuse me executive session I've
held so many public hearings lately XP
um 643
and open the public hearing on hb16 the
executive session on hp160
and recognize representative Harry
gathright for a motion
second Mr chair
thank you representative gather would
you like to speak to your motion yeah
um I understand the intent of the bill
however no matter what the crime I truly
believe that
um
the description
of anything rather it's mental illness
or anything else or in in
how would I say that in dealing with the
crime
um that discretion should go to the
judge I don't believe that we as
lawmakers should write laws to say what
the judge can can't do and can do
so I thought it was a discretionary
issue because
um oh
judge
right
I'm just making sure because you're the
same
no I was saying that I believe that a
judge should make make the call not you
know
um us as lawmakers here that's what I
was saying
um
so um the other piece of that is that we
had her testimony of a couple towns that
um in specific as to what the issue was
and then I also had an issue that there
were two males honestly that came here
to with a bill like that
um
so I just didn't like the bill all
across the town I have 13 grandchildren
and I definitely feel that they don't
need to be walking down the street in
Nashua and seeing um women or anybody
topless to be honest with you because in
for me they probably should have came
with a bill to
um
arrest the person the male as well if
they were topless I don't feel as though
they should be walking around without
shirts as well so
I'm definitely against the bill so I I
moved it thank you representative
Catherine representative Rhodes would
you like to speak to your second thank
you Mr chair I I agree with um
everything my my colleague and friend
said and I
you know I I just think
what what are we doing here right I I
just don't think that anybody in society
should be walking around without a shirt
on and I agree I don't think the male
should be doing it either and I think we
need to think of our of our youth and
um you know exactly exactly what kind of
message that we're sending so
pretty much it
representative Murray
I would just um thank you Mr chair I
would like to remind the committee that
it is already legal in the state of New
Hampshire to be topless whether in
Nashua Manchester Etc it is already
legal
um this bill would just override the
local ordinances by towns like laconian
I believe Milford is the other one who
have local ordinances that prohibit
female toplessness but across the state
of New Hampshire it is already legal for
anybody to be topless
thank you for that reminder
representative salik
thank you Mr chair I have to admit I am
on one hand I oppose discrimination in
all of its forms
um and and I agree if we're going to
have a bill about who should wear shirts
it should be or cover their nipples it
should be everyone so you know uh
representative Heinz could provide both
men and women with pasties if needed but
um ultimately what comes down to for me
and where I'm really concerned is the
idea that we should be overriding a
municipal ordinance
and I spoke with
um the representative from the um one of
the municipal associations to just get a
better sense of how this would impact if
if this bill would essentially set a
precedent for our overriding local
statutes and local ordinances and his
feeling was that it potentially does
that and so I I honestly don't know how
I'm going to vote when we get to the
vote but I I really am struggling with
the concept of overriding what a town
believes in its best interest just as I
know like in the town where I live we
have ordinances that are very specific
because they're directly relevant to how
our town is structured that it would be
completely irrelevant in the towns of
anyone else who serves on this committee
foreign
thankfully I'm not conflicted I I
represent Hampton and part of that is
Hampton beach Hampton Beach State Park
has an annual event free the nipple
um
so
to go a little bit further into that
I've served on a municipal budget
committee municipal
planning board
and I realized that New Hampshire is a
Dillon State Dylan rule state so if the
state doesn't give you if the state has
been silent the legislature has been
silent that's our prohibition for a
municipality
that covers cities and towns from
passing any type of ordinance in that in
that subject matter and whereas this
legislature has never spoken against
displaying of the chest
these these municipalities should not be
passing ordinances in that effect so
uh
I I won't be voting for The ITIL as a
matter of fact I'd offer to write a
Minority Report
thank you representative um and your
point is also well taken however I would
I would assume in that state we would um
under those circumstances the courts
would be the one to resolve whether or
not they are authorized or within their
rights to uh under dillonsville state to
be doing that
um representative Newell
um I would like to just just comment on
uh the idea that we on the state level
um
in my opinion what we do is we set a
Level Playing Field and what's happening
in these towns is that there are
um ordinances being made that are
explicitly
um sexist and based on
um on the the perception in
sexualization of a woman's body and I
think that
um yes I will I will be voting against
the itl because I think that it is our
responsibility in this body to set a
Level Playing Field when uh individual
municipalities may make ordinances that
go against that fundamental value
thank you I would I would again
reiterate though that
we did set a Level Playing Field this is
a Dylan real estate and the answer to
that is through the judicial branch if
uh if a local municipality passes an
ordinance that they are not within their
rights to pass it would be up to the
judicial branch to look at that and say
you you can't do that if we were to
write laws trying to cover every
municipality that passes something that
we don't think they should we would be
playing whack-a-mole up here writing
bills every year but your point is well
taken representative here Gathering
oh and I saw you representative Murphy
you'll be next I'm sorry sorry I also
wanted to mention that um remember they
gave he gave testimony and he sent us
the documentation for um he had gone to
the local court and to the Supreme Court
and um they both ruled against him
so yes thank you representative Murphy
thank you Mr chair
um actually that was what I was going to
say as a member of a town governing body
myself I recognize that certain issues
uh pertain maybe only to certain
communities and this isn't one for my
community but for communities that it
impacts I would hate to see that local
control removed so I will be supporting
uh an itl and secondly you know I think
reading the superior excuse me the
supreme court judgment which was issued
in February 2019
um it just it helped me to confirm uh my
my views on it so thank you
thank you at this time I'll ask the
clerk to call the roll oh I'm sorry
represent wheeler just really quickly Mr
chairman I just wanted to say I I I
appreciate everything that's been said
for me I'm voting against the Italian
motion because I don't think that
wearing not being shirtless should be
illegal I think whether you're and right
now you're being a man and being
shirtless is a legal uh you can you can
do that and we should equalize it in
being shirtless should not be a crime
I would ask you how long you would go
outside right now I'm shirtless well I
will be the Polar Plunge you know
the clerk will uh call the roll
Vice chair Rhodes yes
representative Pratt
representative Hill yes representative
sellers yes
representative janvin
no representative Manion
yes
representative Reed
representative Stone yes
representative tanzar yes
representative Harriet gothright
representative Muse
yes
representative Bolden I'm sorry remind
me of the motion Ito no
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Newman
yes
the clerk votes no representative Newell
no
representative selig
representative wheeler
chairman Roy terrible GS
motion passes 14 yeah six nay
representative chairman you'll be
writing The Minority Report
yes nominatory report will be OTP
yeah and if I could have it by Tuesday
at noon I'd appreciate it and who will
be writing the majority who made the
motion
representative gas right
um if you could Tuesday at noon please
and this time I'll close the executive
session on
hb160 and
um
and open the executive session on hp201
and I will recognize representative
stone for a motion thank you Mr chair I
would like to recommend motioning to uh
itl House Bill 201
seconds okay
I'll second Mr chair
representative Stone would you like to
speak to your motion
Mr chair I would
House Bill 201 would be going backwards
in regards to Public Safety the
operation of a motor vehicle is a
serious action that can result in
serious bodily injury or death a lot of
times we take it for granted operating a
motor vehicle and I think the penalties
that are currently in existence are
sufficient
representative speak to you a second
thank you Mr chairman
when you get a driver's license
there are a set of roles that you
agree to to abide by and having it
renewed
is one of them and I do believe that
you know we've all get busy and oh my
gosh your birthday month comes and goes
and you you didn't go down and have your
license renewed
but honestly uh if if you are to be
pulled over for that which I admittedly
have been
um
you know I I had the opportunity to to
go do that and but to just not let it go
and and to have an excuse for that
and to just make that all be okay I I
don't agree with and I I think that it's
it's it's pretty evident when you get
your license that's what you have to do
thank you um discussion
representative sailing
thank you I I disagree with itl I
believe this motion
ought to pass I think about the
number of
um
immigrants who come to our country
whether as refugees or through other
channels who may not have fully
understood all of our laws and May
inadvertently violate this law because
it's not similar to something in their
own country
and that for them to to
um
be convicted I believe it's right now uh
felony it's something high level for a
first offense at this point I don't I
believe the penalty currently is too
strong I also think about the fact that
I have a teenager who's learning to
drive and
um it's hypothetically possible that we
might have started before the day she
turned 15 and a half
and this law would technically put her
in the same category
um for in terms of the levels of
violations and I
I think it's too strong
representative Murray
thank you Mr chair
um I believe that we should well I will
be voting against the itl I believe that
this bill should be ought to pass
um as the wording
allows for
further to increase penalties for those
who have repeated offenses against
driving without a license but it would
only change the first time violation
to not be a Class B misdemeanor and I
think that allows for understandable
mistakes such as a teenager taking out
their parents car or someone forgetting
to renew their license I don't think
someone who you know forgets to renew
their license should get a Class B
misdemeanor for being busy during the
normal business hours that a DMV is open
and I think lowering the initial penalty
and leaving the increased penalty for
repeated offenses is a good way to
logically address this
I would just um point out to the members
who have spoken that currently if you do
make that mistake or your teenager makes
that mistake or a new arrival to our
country makes that mistake the first
offense is a violation it's not a
misdemeanor not a felony it's a
violation which is just a fine
so really that is not something that
would be alleviated by this bill under
the current one
no this is the old text that's this is
the new
so just um asking that you keep that in
mind
and compare the two versions of the bill
before you make your mind representative
Pratt
I have a friend who uh became a citizen
part of the naturalization process was
for them to learn the laws and a lot of
the taxes they have to pay and that's a
big section of what they have to learn
is make sure they pay their taxes make
sure they uh follow the laws so that's
part of the naturalization process that
he went through and it was very
important that you go through that
process without that process this could
happen
so I'm against it
representative Newman
my concern would not be is mostly for
the people that were brought to this
country when they were infants or or no
so and do not have the capability
to get a driver's license legally that I
know of there may be some states that
have passed laws that allowed them to
have driver's license which I think is
the correct
thing to do so therefore I'm I'm going
to vote
and I have to remember which way that is
I will take you away
I will vote
and uh
yeah I'm going to vote against the itl
thank you representative Newell
yeah I would agree I'm going to vote
against the itl um and I think you know
I I consider it essentially a clerical
error one that I've been guilty of many
times
um there are so many situations in which
just forgetting to forgetting to go to
the DMV not having the the money to
renew your license um there's a variety
of reasons why someone would just
innocently not be able to renew their
license or
um or uh you know be on the app it up
paperwork wise I mean at the end of the
day it's paperwork so yeah I think
lowering the lowering the penalties and
understanding that there are so many
different reasons without
um putting someone in the situation
where they have to demonstrate those
reasons is probably the right default in
my my opinion
thank you
is a sponsor of this bill present
no
the committee would like to invite you
to uh if you wouldn't mind
um as we're having a little confusion
and discussion about the bill
and here I was trying to thank you Mr
chairman
um I'm representative George Sykes from
Lebanon New Hampshire I represent
Grafton uh count Grafton 14 now it
changed for the last redistricting which
is Ward 2. I am the prime sponsor of
this bill and thank you for
consideration I actually tried to be a
little bit Incognito my only purpose in
coming this morning was to
um Mr chairman you were kind enough to
understand that because of various uh
personal medical issues for family I was
not able to come and introduce the bill
originally and I wanted to show respect
to the committee that
um
it matters to me what you're trying to
do here and that that's why I showed up
today if you had some questions I don't
have a copy of the bill with me I'll try
to answer them if you wish
um
but anyways there we are
would anyone like to inquire of the
sponsor representative Murray
am I correct in my understanding of the
bill that it would change it so anyone
who has never had a license in the state
of New Hampshire was pulled over for
driving without you know that filed
license would then only get a violation
instead of a Class B misdemeanor and
anyone who had a driver's license that
would have expired it does not change
the current law which is that they would
only get a violation on a Class B
misdemeanor so really it's only changing
for those who have not had a license yet
that is my understanding as well first
time if your license expires and you get
stopped for the first time it is still a
violation if you continue to not get
your driver's license then it would move
into
a misdemeanor thank you for the question
representative Murphy would you like to
inquire
nope 72 left
representative Muse would you like to
inquire the sponsor yes
um for an undocumented person uh to
actually uh be charged and convicted of
a class B felony
what does that do to their immigration
status
yeah I'm sorry so there is a connection
obviously if if a person were to be
undocumented and be stopped and then
charged with not having a driver's
license it would be a misdemeanor but
they would then typically uh
trickle down to uh
immigration issue as well
so far in the questions that have been
asked and I'm not sure and my apologies
I wasn't here for the hearing so I don't
quite know what you you know we all
heard that day but I would apparently
knew the news so well you're okay
yeah
um but I I would like to remind everyone
too that one of the one of the issues
about
um driver's license issues is
uh typically problems with keeping
getting your driver's license on time or
getting your license at all sometimes
is a financial issue as well and there's
a certain amount of people who where it
becomes more difficult if you're poor
and this would help in that regard as
well
not just it's not just about a narrowly
defined issue but thank you for allowing
me to testify now
um representative Rhodes thank you Mr
chair
I I just want to confirm because it's my
understanding you can renew your
driver's license online now right you
don't have to actually go during certain
hours
to the DMV while they're open is that
yes you are you can't thank you for the
question
um you can renew your driver's license
once online you can't do it forever
um but you can do it once
look at the representative Hill who's on
Transportation with me so representative
Newell
I I would just acknowledge that while
these things seem like small barriers of
you know online access the financial
barrier I mean these are impediments to
people in difficult situations well
maybe none of us on this committee have
been in a situation where that was
significant enough to be a a significant
barrier to you but I've been in that
situation in the past so I mean I just I
think it's it's good to take that into
account not everybody has the means that
that we necessarily do okay uh thank you
for your assistance and
representative Newman would you like to
inquire I just have one one question
about something that you testified to
that if someone does not have a license
and they are stopped for the first time
did you say that was a misdemeanor or
could be a misdemeanor somehow because
of another law and I'm thinking that
might no yes an expired first stop is a
violation but a no driver's license
first time my understanding is that it's
a would move to misdemeanor and one the
only other thing if I if you would
indulge me Mr chairman you've been so
kind
um this bill came about as a result of a
study committee that Transportation
undertook
and the one of the participants the in
fact the primary driver between behind
this was chief justice Nadu who this was
one of her recommendations that the
legislature try and achieve this purpose
and so there was a lot going on why this
bill has been introduced and thank you
and again I I appreciate everyone's
Indulgence and thank you to the
committee
thank you very much
also thank you to the transportation
committee study committee to give a bill
to criminal justice that was very kind
of you
uh yes representative Manion
just some clarification this is how I
understand the current bill is if you're
expired which you have a license that's
just expired your first offense of the
violation second offense will be a Class
B misdemeanor in a 12-month period I
believe it is
the current bill also says that if
you've never had a license and you're
driving
without regard to getting a license that
first offense is a B misdemeanor this
law moves to change that so that in both
cases it's a violation for first offense
B misdemeanor for second offense I don't
know if that clarifies it for people it
doesn't and I would um my comment on
that is I don't think that we should be
treating people who went to the trouble
to get their driver's license go to
Driving School spend enormous amount of
money to do that and go through the
process
the same as someone who never bothered
to do any of those things
um one is a misdemeanor because they
never even acknowledge the the
responsibility to get a driver's license
which puts the entire motoring public
danger because they obviously aren't
insured if you operate a motor vehicle
with no driver's license it's dubious as
to whether or not the insurance company
will cover you in an event of an
accident so there are a lot of things I
understand the the impact it can have on
someone who who may be new to the
country or into the country on in an
undocumented status but we as a policy
committee should not be writing laws to
accommodate people who aren't who aren't
necessarily here following the rules
because they don't understand it I mean
I I have empathy for that situation but
at the same time I have empathy for the
motoring public who could be injured by
someone and have no insurance to cover
them if they are their family or her
representative Murray
thank you Mr chair
um I would just like to share with the
committee um some of my own personal
experience with this I was homeschooled
here in New Hampshire and I grew up in a
rural area and I since I was
homeschooled I didn't have access to
um driving school at Public School my
parents didn't have the money to pay for
me to go to
um Drivers School
and so I didn't get my license until I
was 19. and even though I mostly biked
or walked everywhere occasionally I did
have to under extreme circumstances
drive my parents car without a license
and I did get pulled over once but
because I was driving safely and the
cops knew me
um I was not charged with anything but
um I would just like to remind the
committee that this definitely impacts
young people in New Hampshire especially
in these rural areas especially those
who are homeschooled who don't have
access to driving school or for other
reasons may be not able to get their
license until they're older
I I agree and I I actually supported a
bill that would allow parents to um
legally Legally give driver's EDS but
that meant an unfortunate demise uh um I
would I would agree with you I too grew
up in a small community I never got my
driver's license until I actually joined
the army and I got my first driver's
license I believe it was an m577 tank
um that I was first licensed to drive in
in yeah and then um a Jeep and a Humvee
and several other things the point being
I didn't have the money for any of that
and I ended up getting it in the
military first but to think that we
would say well you know it's tough so
there's certain people you don't have to
it's it's extremely troubling and again
I go back to the insurance issue that
really worries me is if you end up with
a child in another vehicle who was
equally as poor as the person who
couldn't afford to get their license now
is a paraplegic for the rest of their
life and how is that family going to
afford to take care of that child with
no insurance coverage because the other
a person decided that they didn't need
to get a license
representative salic
thank you
I would like to add for for several
years the University of New
hip did a partnership with a university
in China where we had a huge number of
students coming and in their country
driver's licenses are not part of their
culture at all so these students came
here and truly did not know based on
their experience so we had a series of
circumstances of them driving not
necessarily safely and they were all
stopped for that and it was determined
that they did not understand
based on the immigration process all of
which was done completely legally with
visas and all of the due process that
was appropriate but they no one had had
given them the information they weren't
trying to evade anything but a
misdemeanor for something like that
would have compromised their visas
forced them not to be able to pay their
extensive high-level tuition to UNH
among other things and so an education
plan was put in place so that when they
arrived there was a whole program in
order to teach them and educate them so
it stopped the practice again to give
them a a misdemeanor for something that
really should have been a violation that
could be used as an educational
experience was really the most was not
would not have been appropriate so again
there are all sorts of different
circumstances I don't dispute that there
are people who knowingly violate this
law and violate it on a regular basis
which is why for second third and fourth
offenses I think there's a it's
appropriate to have much steeper
penalties but I do believe that people
should be a 4 an opportunity to
understand okay I violated this
particular provision
whether knowingly or unknowingly but not
with the intent of harming someone
obviously if they're driving recklessly
that's a whole separate set of
conditions that's different from just
not having your physical license and so
if someone is driving recklessly that
they should be certainly charged with
that as a separate
um whatever the word is I'm sorry my
offense thank you sorry I haven't had
enough coffee today
um and we should recognize that but but
this specific thing I I believe this I
support that this should pass
thank you I I understand about the
Chinese immigrants that's interesting um
that they don't in their culture don't
have to have that apparently they don't
have um anything about floating giant
spy balloons over our country either
because there's one over Montana right
now I I would say that that is well that
is true and probably not relevant we
also have a huge number of spy
elements of our own over their country
and I they do not hesitate to shoot them
down uh representative Stone
thank you Mr chairman I'd like to remind
the committee that the reason to get a
license is it measures your knowledge
you have to pass a written test and
additionally you have to pass a
practical test to make sure that you are
safe and roadworthy those two
requirements are very important to be
issued a license I think by negating
that you would be creating a really
hazardous condition for Public Safety
overall thank you
I think representative Reed thank you Mr
chairman
um just because somebody gets stopped
and perhaps you know get a misdemeanor
doesn't mean they're going to tell it to
the judge and it doesn't mean it's going
to stick so if those chain if the the
people who were stopped without a
license felt that they did it the judge
can make the determination correct
yes that's correct just because it says
here that's the punishment does not by
any stretch of the imagination I mean
it's actually going to happen
um I think the police would be the first
to agree with that and so you have
several levels of discretion the police
officer can use his discretion not to
write a citation or or make the
complaint you have the district attorney
who might also null across the complaint
then you have the judge who might say
okay so you've got three levels at least
of people who are going to look at that
who could say okay this is you know
clearly they didn't understand so for us
to put a broad brush and say we're going
to take that discretion away because we
don't trust that system to me is uh
disturbing representative Murray and
that'll be the last one because I think
we agree we're where we're at
thank you Mr chair
um I just wanted to emphasize to the
committee the fact that this only
addresses the first violation if there
were another instance of driving without
a license within a 12-month period they
would get a Class B misdemeanor so this
is not encouraging any type of
conditions for people to be driving
around without a license recklessly and
getting pulled over and over again
without consequences and also to address
representative Muse's question earlier
about how this might a Class B
misdemeanor could impact immigrants it
is not automatic grounds for
um expulsion from the country but it can
lead to that
thank you um I would ask the clerk to
call the roll at this point
and the motion on the floor is
inexpedient to legislate
Vice chair Rhodes yes
representative Pratt yes
representative Hill yes
representative sellers yes
representative janvrin yes
representative mannion yes
representative Reed
representative Stone yes representative
tensar yes
representative Harry Gathering
representative muse no representative
Bolden
no representative Bradley no
representative Murphy no
representative Newman no
the clerk votes no representative Newell
no
Representative selig no
representative wheeler
chairman Roy Cheryl GS
10 10.
the motion fails
I would remind you that it's open now to
another motion however I would
anticipate the vote will be exactly the
same so
um does anyone wish to make another
motion representative salik I move the
motion ought to pass
I'm gonna put on my amazing crescan hat
and
anticipate a 10 10.
representative selig would you like to
speak to your motion
for all the reasons that I explained in
our previous conversation that was very
kind of you right representative Harriet
gather right would you like to speak to
you a second
only just to remind you again that the
committee again that um it's a first
offense so I really think the violation
was the correct
you know whatever
representative Murray
I also would just uh thank you Mr chair
I'd like to remind the committee that
this bill came out of a study committee
from the Transportation committee and I
think that we can trust that they've
done the work necessary
um
to study all these implications of this
bill
representative Muse
I also wanted to just remind everybody
really quickly that we're not talking
about waving a penalty here so people
who actually commit commit this crime
are are not going to go unpunished
um uh a violation it'll be a violation
level offense and I and I think one of
the reasons for us to to pretty strongly
consider consider something like that is
the impact that it can actually do to
somebody's immigration status
this is something that can get you sent
out of the country and many times
somebody who's new to the country is in
a financial situation where maybe it's
everything that they can afford to be
able to buy a car and the only way
they're going to make their car payments
is if they're able to take that car to
work and they can continue to be
employed employed so it it's a it's a
very difficult Balancing Act
um that that folks have to go through
um but just a reminder that if they're
pulled over and there's stopped they're
still subject to a penalty you know
we're not this is not a you know the
equivalent of a get out of jail free
card but what I do think it is is a more
a more sensible and appropriate penalty
for somebody who's being charged for the
first time and I think this is a
question that really comes up a lot in
in our committee when it comes to
penalties for first-time offenders
um you know to what extent do we want
somebody who's a first-time offender to
go through life with with a criminal
record
um and is you know is is this is this
offense really you know does does it
reach that level and I know we've had
extensive debate as to whether or not it
does or not
um but but I do think you know the fact
that uh the fact that people are are
going to be penalized is just something
that we really do need to remember
thank you
um representative Hill do you have any
input into this
being your origin
um thank you Mr chair
um just a couple of
couple of quick things
um one is while it did go through a
study committee
I'm trying in vain to find actually what
the outcome of the study committee was
it it may have just entered the study
committee and come out as no
recommendation and I don't I don't have
that in front of me and I can't find it
um quickly but um there are
it's not necessarily an immigration
issue and I will tell you that we are
currently battling this same question or
or uh tangentially this same question in
transportation
I'm not sure if we're dealing with the
the cart before the horse or not the
penalty before we get to the point of
determining how we handle
um those here illegally and applying for
Asylum or those that are here illegally
and driving
illegally it really is the second
offense that we're dealing with they're
here illegally and they're driving
illegally so
um I will be supporting well now I will
be voting against the ought to pass and
I'm sure we're going to end up in the
same spot and we're all saying the same
thing for this motion as we did in the
past motion so I would assume we're
going to end up with no recommendation
thank you and thank you I appreciate uh
giving your role in transportation
adding to the um discussion
um I think oh representative salik sir
one other thing um I just was thinking
about representative Reed's comment in
the previous discussion about the person
can
take their misdemeanor to the prosecutor
and to the judge and to everything else
and in all of the testimony we've heard
it's been about how overwhelmed the
prosecutor's office is how overwhelmed
the public defender's office is and how
overwhelmed our judicial system is and
so if we're saying that something that's
a relatively minor issue that should for
first offense only I'm not talking about
subsequent offenses but that could be
handled as
um without needing the court system
would ultimately save all of those
systems tremendous amounts of money as
well as time and just something else to
be considered
thank you for that and I'm gonna close
the discussion by just reminding
everyone my the main reason for my
position is that it it could potentially
um set up not only the operator but the
people that if they're involved in an
accident any kind of insurance coverage
for whatever happens horrifically
um and and that to me is a it's a very
very serious thing when you can end up
with someone with medical bills for the
rest of their lives who is equally as
poor or potentially even also an
immigrant
um and not have coverage because of that
so with that I lost the clerk to call
the rule
and a reminder that the motion on the
floor is ought to pass
Vice chair Rhodes no
representative Pratt no representative
Hill no representative sellers no
Representative janvin no
representative Manion no
representative Reed
representative Stone no
Representative tensar no
representative Harriet gathright
representative Muse yes representative
Bolden yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Newman
yes
uh the clerk votes yes representative
Newell yes
representative selig yes
representative wheeler
chairman Roy Geralds no
10 10.
once again I am Nostradamus
and with that I will who is going to be
roading right oh so it comes with no
recommendations so we would each I
believe write a a report so who would
like to write the report for the OTP
no it's automatic
I suppose you will okay so by Tuesday at
noon if you don't mind and who would
like to write it who made the first
motion representative Stone would you
write it thank you very much and with
that I will close the public hearing on
what was this bill HP 201 uh Mr chair
executive session needs to be 201
can we take a 10-minute recess I was
about to say we are going to take a
15-minute bio break
s
so I'll find out
vote
15 minutes
I don't know
so
um
right
excuse me
thank you
sometimes if I hit GPS with a lot of
electricity yeah that's why you give me
a shout out when you would hear that
he's a nice guy yeah very knowledgeable
but I was fine controlling my emotions
foreign
we just got four none of the generations
but these guys
why don't you just drive back to your
house and pack it my brother since
you're in the business
that's odd job not good job get back in
your car someone as long as being
penalized
screened there and these guys are going
to drive a bus now with this stop right
yeah so if they smash up again
you know they have no license they never
have dogs even show up before
okay
and now you should not make it Vlogs to
make it happen right I agree with you
Kevin 100 and you know and I'm trying to
figure it you know kind of hearing on
the level of Staff assistance
as a nurse since 1991 we've worked
shortstack shorts
you have a job to do you do it whether
you're voters understand
or not that's not an excuse no no they
uh they really dump up an essays they
really have a job I almost got Dr help
them yes emergency
you know and those are people's lives
you deal with you know and maybe they
get the job done yeah so you know even
though they're that's that's just the
beginning
yeah
so yeah I agree with you it's not the
point around Down Here Without license
you know so many people probably like
Chinese people they will never even have
a driver's license to begin with so I'll
let you know when you have an experience
behind the wheel it's a very scary in
some country it probably used to drive
yeah
they can drive any piece of junk down
there right then you have to stick
around and it can be a motorcycle
without Tire everything else
it's it's scary all good things it is
yeah
I I just feel that we're going to end up
being a six Gun City Style in our
country
you know it's a wee type problems
in Massachusetts
they wanted to make the license for you
I wouldn't mind the ACT I can't make it
so that we have to pass test a driving
test and I've written a text once you've
been showing you stay within the line
you can stop at a stop sign and use your
direction or like they never do
what does that says
it refers that's referred to this guy
foreign
yeah primary world you can stop signs on
a secondary Road and you just let
traffic control itself but uh to produce
which is stupid you have big trucks
trying to go around and take it up two
lanes and they're so shut up like God
they were so stupid yeah they made two
down there and a lot of things I can't
get around until I say you can drive
with one occur right she's not a good
place it's all uh cobblestones right
right so the they rebuild them to put a
lot of people about just tease me off
the Raymond they've got two inches of
rain and they've been teachers so you
have to actually by a lot of people used
to having a boss with one lane two lanes
to get out of the bottom and it's just
not designed where somebody stops
whether it's supposed to stop I tell you
where we will come around
stupid questions can't go down easily
they're not well thought out I only want
to make it a nice little village you
know the aesthetic well the vehicle's
got a nice little Vehicles anymore you
know when they hit the wagon game on
your floor it was small but now they get
these are inches down yellow and green
trucks and propane trucks yeah
you're gonna make the road nice and cute
they took a bit of sidewalk
and went to the road and they made it
like 16 feet wide between three feet of
a grass they put trees in it so it
looked good it's a fortunate that's what
I call it and the trees are directly
underneath the whites so when they grow
up
right how can they not figure that out
you know it's not about sidewalks how
they're stupid enough to put a tree
right underneath the wires all the time
over and over again in that town and uh
eventually that thing will grow up
eventually they'll have to cut it off
and put a hole for it right it will look
terrible right or it'll just go through
the wire
all right they do it over and over again
because they have no thought but it's
good enough so the whole time
raised and if power truck will go down
and clean it off right right yes right
it was open yeah
now a way to get grass and trees
he was just one year with so many snows
gone he was trying to go back and forth
and they had to camp
foreign
at this time I'm opening the executive
session on House Bill 291.
and I recognize a representative Rhodes
for a motion thank you Mr chairman I
would like to make a motion of itl for
House Bill 291
a second
thank you representative Rhodes would
you like to speak to your motion
Mr chairman um
briefly while I
I do believe on the
on the surface you know it it certainly
is in line with you know the thoughts of
it's not okay to go to an apartment and
and lie and make false accusations it it
puts the department out to have to do
investigation it all the employees
um it's not sending an okay message it's
okay to go make these false reports but
on the other hand it was very specific
to really one Department
um
and I I think overall that the general
census is that you know most people are
not doing that and sometimes I think it
might be a Vengeance situation but I
don't think that we want to set laws
based on just vengeance
representative uh Harry gaps right would
you like to speak to you a second I
think it was
open for discussion
seeing none I I would simply say that I
concur with the the itl
um
there are remedies currently in civil
law for someone who Slanders or or
um
makes false statements against a
business or a person and there are
remedies for that I know it's not the
most convenient way to do it but I'm
cherry picking agencies to
or that are
attached penalties to them I think it's
it's um sets a bad precedent so I'm
gonna I'll follow along with that and go
with an Ito at this time I would ask the
clerk to call the roll
Vice chair Rhodes yes
representative Pratt
yes
representative Hill yes
representative sellers yes
representative janfrin
yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed
representative Stone yes
representative tenzar yes
representative Harriet gothright
representative Muse yes representative
Bolden
yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Newman
yes
the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
selig yes
representative wheeler
chairman Roy gerbilts yes
motion passes 20-0
any objection to consent
none
content will be I closed public hearing
on HP 291 at this time I'm going to open
a public hearing I'm going to call it a
little out of order in deference to a
sponsor who has to be somewhere else and
wanted to be here for uh what we decide
to do and that is
HP 144
and I recognize representative jandron
to make a motion
Mr chairman I move to retain house bill
144. and to appoint is there a second
second
would you like to speak to your motion
yes I believe there's some Merit to some
offenses being uh listed specifically
listed
to allow restoring of firearm ownership
not all felonies are violent but some
that were testified in the hearing
although they may not be non-violent
still
could be considered reasons why we
wouldn't want to restore those rights so
I'd like to have a subcommittee to work
on a
uh a list of what felonies we are
talking about specifically
thank you representative Stone would you
like to speak to you second
thank you Mr chairman I would like to
say that I think this bill deserves some
further review and see what else we
could come up with out of it see if it's
better streamlined thank you I would say
that you both read my mind and to that
end I'm going to appoint a subcommittee
um if the vote to retain passes and just
to let you know who will be on that
subcommittee it will be
um Representatives
excuse me I don't have that one but
where's
it
thank you
um and that subcommittee is going to be
chaired by representative janvren and
it's going to have on it Representatives
read Stone
Newell
now this isn't the right one okay
Jamberry tensor Stone Murphy and Wheeler
does everyone make a note of that that
you're on that subcommittee
um with that as there's any more
discussion we'll go ahead and vote to
retain
seeing none go ahead and call the roll
the motion is to retain Vice chair
Rhodes yes
representative Pratt
yes
representative Hill yes representative
sellers yes
representative janvin yes representative
Manion yes representative Reed
representative Stone yes
representative tanzar yes representative
Harriet gothright
representative Muse
yes
representative Bolden yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy
yes
representative Newman
yes the clerk votes yes representative
Newell yes
representative selik
um yes
representative wheeler
chairman Roy cheer votes yes motion
passes 22. okay so that bill is retained
in um the the
mandate for the subcommittee is to come
up with a detailed list of offenses that
we feel we could allow uh the return of
firearms rights to and those to which we
do not and um you can begin working on
that as soon as you're able
um at that point I'm going to close the
public hearing on HP 144.
executive session on HP 144 and opened
the executive session on HB what's the
next one 287.
and I recognize
representative Manion
which one
represent a man you need to make a
motion
I believe it's read on this one
excuse me representative Reed to make a
motion thank you Mr chairman I moved to
um
to retain bill 287.
10 seconds
would you like to speak the emotion
representative
although this bill has Merit it deserves
further study thank you
would you like to speak to your second
representative I agree with
representative
any discussion
I'll add we're going to appoint a
subcommittee on this to work on this
bill
um because
we have two bills that basically do the
same thing and we want to spend just a
little bit of time on that and I'm
making sure that we get the best parts
of both of those bills I think we all
agree that it is a good idea to provide
this testing ability and we want to make
sure I understand there's a emotion I
mean excuse me an amendment coming and I
would like to take and look at both of
them and conceal it into one bill this
will be a short subcommittee and we
should probably deal with it rather
quickly
any more discussion
representative Newell
uh I agree uh that this and
um 287 should be considered and figure
out the best way forward I guess what I
would just want to say is is that we
keep in mind the urgency
um of what what uh getting this done in
a timely manner
I agree but I I think it's equally as
important to make sure we come together
as a committee and everyone agrees on it
um
so you know further discussion the
collect will call the role
so
motion is retain Vice chair Rhodes yes
representative Pratt
yes
representative Hill yes representative
sellers yes
representative Jan Fran yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed
representative Stone yes
representative tanzar yes
representative Harriet gothright
representative Muse yes
representative Bolden yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes
the clerk votes yes representative
Newell yes
representative Selleck yes
representative wheeler
chairman Roy Charles yes
motion passes 19-1
with that um
HP 287 is retained and I closed the
executive session I opened the executive
session on HB 470 and recognize
representative janvin for a motion
my motion is also to retain this and put
it to the Samsung committee
is there a second second
would you like to speak to your motion
uh I think it applies that both House
Bill 470 and 287 have merits and we'd
like to reconcile the bills
thank you would you like to speak to you
second
I would concur
thank you I would say that um I uh it's
the same thing I just said
um we like both bills one perhaps a
little more than the other but I'd like
to make sure that we take a moment and
ensure that we come up with the best
product that we can all support
unanimously and I will be appointing a
subcommittee if we agree to retain this
one and on that subcommittee will be
chaired by representative Manion and
we'll have representative Reed Stone
Newell and Muse
um with that any further discussion
representative Murray
thank you Mr chair
um my suggestion to the committee would
be to
um
OTP The Spill
um while we work on the other one as
representative Newell mentioned earlier
this is an urgent issue that impacts
people every day on whether or not they
are taking drugs that are safe or not
and
um in my opinion people could die if we
don't pass legislation like this sooner
I agree uh that it is an urgent bill
um I have a quick question hold on a
second
I'm going to um ask the two people who
made a motion if they'd be willing to
withdraw it and then hear me out
Mr chairman I'm just looking now at the
house deadlines we have until March 16th
to report this bill out and I would
agree I'll withdraw my emotion
oh I will draw thank you um with that
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
recess the executive session on this and
we're going to have a committee work
session and we're going to hammer this
out now sometime in the next couple
weeks and come up with the product now
rather than wait until January to come
out with a does that make everyone feel
a little bit better
I'm all about the warm and fuzzies
Okay so we've withdrawn the motion to
retain that bill what we're going to do
is I'm going to recess the executive
session we're going to I'm going to
schedule a full committee work session
we're going to come in here to deal with
just that bill and we're going to merge
it with the other Bill and come up with
the best product and we're going to get
it done this year and we're going to
bring it to the floor next month
would you like me to not do that okay
may make a request please just for for
people setting up subcommittee meetings
if they could just let the other people
on the subcommittee have an idea of
scheduling in with sufficient notice
especially on days we're not generally
intended to be here that would be really
helpful if everyone who's in charge of
subcommittee heard that please give your
members adequate notice and I will
certain this is going to be a full
committee work session not a
subcommittee so we'll all be here
together
um so bring your lunch I'll let you know
when it is so with that I am going to
recess
foreign
to and you will be notified of when the
work session is
and with that I'm going to open the pot
no the executive session on House Bill
292 I believe is next
and recognize
292 representative Rhodes promotion
well thank you Mr chair if you could
just give me one second
time I would like to make a motion of
itl for house bill 292.
I don't know
thank you representative Rhodes would
you like to speak to your motion
thank you um
is unfortunate as is that I think we all
agree that sometimes
um there may be a meeting that we prefer
had not taken place maybe maybe it did
maybe it didn't
um this is more of a 91a issue it it is
illegal to hold a
an illegal meeting already
um but it is generally frowned upon by
the entire legislative body to
to have personal penalties for an
individual member of a board and um
for for that reason I
like right to the quick is just uh to I
tell it
representative would you like to speak
to a second
discussion
I would just add that
um these are volunteer positions and
oftentimes the people that are doing it
um would not do it if they were realized
they were at such significant financial
risk regardless of whether or not they
they made something a mistake or an
attempt representative Newman you seem
to be wanting to say something
and I agree I think that this bill
should be itl
and but my reason for it is is in
section two line nine where it gives any
individual the private right to sue a
public official when they did X Y or Z
and I think that take kind of takes it
out of the criminal justice system and
puts it in the Civil system and I'm
opposed to that kind of language in a
bill
well
I think we all have our individual
regions but we're coming to the same
conclusion with that I will ask the
clerk to call the road
motion on floors in experience legislate
Vice chair Rhodes
yes representative Pratt
representative Hill yes representative
sellers yes representative janvin yes
representative mannion yes
representative Reed
representative Stone yes
representative tensar yes representative
Harriet goth right
representative Muse yes
representative Bolden yes representative
Bradley yes representative Murphy yes
representative Newman
yes
the clerk votes yes representative
Newell yes
representative selig yes representative
wheeler
chairman Roy
terrible GS motion passes 20-0
any objection to consent
be known its own consent
close the public excuse me the executive
session and
um I opened the executive session on HP
and I recognize representative Manion
for a motion
thank you Mr chair I would make a motion
to uh itl hb302 is there a second
representative Stone second
oh representative Murphy did
[Music]
would you like to speak to your motion I
would thank you Mr chair uh this bill
requires police standings and training
Council to provide each candidate for
law enforcement eight hours of training
in the New Hampshire concert I mean the
uh U.S Constitution and the Bill of
Rights and eight hours in the New
Hampshire Constitution as well I can
speak to my personal experience I
graduated in 1995 from the police
academy and I received training all of
those subjects
and as we heard from the director of The
Academy
he provided a fairly comprehensive
binder and actually exceeds some of
these hours that they're currently
teaching and he said he was open to more
uh teaching on this subject as well so I
think this bill is unnecessary and this
this stuff is already being done
representative Murphy would you like to
speak to you second
I concur
thank you
um I I would add that I I think that the
um I thank the sponsor for bringing this
to us our attention and um and so doing
um showing us what we what we are
currently doing and I think that the
standards and training is excellent and
um with that I will ask the clerk to
call the roll the motion is an
experience to legislate
Vice chair Rhodes yes representative
Pratt yes
representative Hill yes
representative sellers yes
representative Jan Finn yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed
representative Stone yes representative
tanzar yes
representative Harry guthright
representative Muse yes
representative Bolden
yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes
the clerk votes yes representative
Newell yes representative selig yes
representative wheeler
chairman Roy terrible GS motion passes
22. any objection to consent
I'm seeing none it will go on consent
with that I closed the public hearing
and H the executive session on hb302
and I need um for um to do this
correctly we
um we we said we were going to um we
close the public uh the executive
session on the which bill was that to do
the test strips
uh Mr chairman I moved reconsideration
of HB 287. thank you and do I have a
second
thank you
um and I'll just you can speak the
emotion involved but I'm just going to
say for technical reasons we agreed to
retain it and that would be the official
thing we have to undo that so that we
can work on it and fix it with the other
bill that we retained that we are going
to work on
Mr chair yeah
we've retained right so if we're undoing
that doesn't the person who made the
motion have to be the one to
does everybody understand let me explain
that that I see some looks the bill that
we retained on the fentanyl test strips
um the other one we did not retain we
left it open and we're going to do a
work session on it but we voted to
retain the other one so the official
record going to the clerk would be
retain we want to not do that we want to
undo that and then leave it open so that
we make also work on it does that
everyone get that so representative
Newman would we then have to have any
other vote to have it be able to be
combined and worked on in a work session
no um no we what we would do is then we
would address both bills once we were
finished working on it and one of them
would be IPL that one of them would move
forward if all things work out great
with that I would ask the clerk to call
the roll on the motion to reconsider
which bill number was that
.
Vice chair Rhodes yes
representative Pratt
yes
representative Hill yes representative
sellers yes
representative Jan Wren yes
representative Manion yes representative
representative Reed
representative Stone yes representative
tensar yes representative Harriet
gathright
representative Muse yes representative
Bolden yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
selig yes
representative wheeler
chairman Roy
chess motion passes 20-0
and at this point I'm going to then
recess
that executive session
um and to be at the call of the chair
I'll let you know when we're going to
work on that
and I believe that concludes our
business for the day
did we cover everything I want to make
sure I covered it in because we jumped
out of order okay if I if I could Mr
chairman
um you've appointed the subcommittee for
House Bill 144 and I looked at the house
calendar I'm sorry the deadlines for the
house I would uh say that in order to
have that subcommittee convened for HB
144 it would more than likely be
after crossover and crossover occurs on
April 6th
because uh I think it's easier to work
on it when we're working on Senate bills
as well it is no there's no
uh
urgency to working on this and and to
put it before the Full House in next
year in January
um let's take that logistic discussion
offline I need to look at that to make
sure
um anyone who was here today that is
interested in uh or following one of the
bills I appointed a subcommittee for I
would encourage you to reach out to the
subcommittee chairs if you want to be a
part of that discussion and with that I
will close our business for the day and
thank you very much
huh
let me just